[Music]
Selena Gomez on love return to acting
Taylor Swift and oh so much more we are
breaking down everything we learned from
her new interview with wsj magazine
first up
Selena's love life Selena says quote
I've been single for over two years now
I'm okay with that she adds that she
loves going to her room at the end of
the day with her pup and stretching out
on the bed in quote full greenie panties
uh-huh amazing her frequent
collaborators Justin Tranter and Julia
Michaels also weighed in Julia says
there was a recent time Selena texted
her saying quote I really just want a
boyfriend the trio then wrote a song
based on that text I want her to being
flourish yeah she deserves it next up Oh
things Taylor Swift
yes Taylor's heard Selena's new album
and she loves it
but Taylor was also interviewed for the
article saying this about their
friendship quote I knew from when I met
her I would always have her back in my
life I have the ability to forgive
people who have hurt me but I don't know
if I can forgive someone who hurts her
yep and I think we all know what that
means
Selena also weighed in on their
friendship saying quote she has showed
up for me in ways that I would have
never expected flown in because I was
hurt and was going through something
it's been proven year after year and in
every moment of my life that she is one
of my best friends in the world hmm
what I love about that that friendship
is it's so solid Sal also talks about
acting and a possible return to TV which
I know is something we all want to see
quote I want to do movies so bad I want
to do TV so bad I find that I look too
young most of the time so I continue to
auditioned and I just have to wait for
whenever my time
and finally Selena gets candid about
mental illness and I just want to say
that I appreciate Selena being so
vulnerable here she admits to
self-esteem problems and says she's been
going to therapy for six years and that
she's been in and out of treatment
facilities quote my highs were really
high and my lows would take me out for
weeks at a time and quote I found out I
do suffer from mental health issues I
got on the right medication and my life
has been it completely changed I'm a
really happy place it's been good
[Music]
next up Selena releases her new album
rare on January 10 more than anything
I'm just I think I feel a sense of
relief you know it's been four years
since I've been working on this album
and it's actually perfect timing because
I was gonna release it two years ago and
none of the the words that I'm speaking
would have existed so taking a moment to
actually feeling the feelings that I've
gone through it's just I don't know I'm
just so grateful that it's out a source
tells ET it'll be her most personal
album yet and it would be stupid of me
if I didn't acknowledge what I had felt
because it would be inauthentic and
that's everything I claimed to be
alright guys that is it for today for
all the latest on selena gomez stick
with all things et until next time I'm
Katie Krause and bye for now
[Music]